tenemos las noticias desde la economía
con Juan Pablo lucumí en Francia 24 Juan
Pablo Un saludo para usted muy buenos
días bueno Juan Pablo nos vamos a
enfocar en hablar de la economía china
después del fin de la política de cero
covid llegaron mejores proyecciones
económicas para el gigante asiático Así
es Ángela vamos directo a las cifras del
crecimiento económico de china en 2022
fue del 3% mientras que la oficina de
estadísticas de China había proyectado
para ese año un crecimiento de por lo
menos un 5,5%, ya muy por debajo del pib
que alcanzó en 2021 que fue del 8,1% o
sea las proyecciones mucho más bajas de
lo esperado el 8 de enero de este año
china reabrió sus fronteras tras casi
tres años del cierre por la pandemia
covid-19 los mercados mundiales y
distintas entidades económicas
recibieron con optimismo la noticia y
llegaron nuevas proyecciones para China
y el resto del mundo el fondo monetario
internacional en enero pasó su previsión
del pib Chino del 4,4% en 2023 que hizo
en octubre al para este año una
previsión que hizo en enero previamente
le preguntamos a Raquel León de la Rosa
qué tanto ayudará esta reactivación
económica de China habitar una recesión
global o mejorar el panorama Financiero
en distintos escenarios desde Puebla
México Raquel no respondió bueno en este
sentido es muy importante el papel de
china debido a que el año pasado por
estas condiciones que bien señalas de la
política de cero covid prácticamente
encontrábamos a uno de los actores más
importantes no solamente en la dinámica
digamos económica sino específicamente
dentro de la economía en la dinámica
comercial sobre todo el tema del
suministro Pero también poco a poco el
tema del consumo no que estuvo si
quieres verlo así participando de manera
muy discreta dentro de la dinámica
Global en la cual Pues bueno eso da como
resultado que se ya se haya rescatado
este dato de que solamente creció en un
tres por ciento que es un porcentaje
Pues creo que el más bajo que ha tenido
China
a lo largo de los últimos este veinte
años no obviamente en este sentido hay
que tomar como que estas precauciones de
decir que no es que de un día para otro
todo cambie sino que comienzan a hacer
proyecciones que son muy favorables por
parte de estas entidades pero que van a
ser graduales no y que también están
este alrededor de otra serie de
elementos No necesariamente vinculados
con china sino en el contexto global una
de las razones que convierten a China en
la segunda Economía del mundo es su tema
de exportaciones globales que por
supuesto se estaban viendo afectadas por
el estricto confinamiento Así es Ángela
exportaciones de tecnología insumos la
industria Automotriz también y vamos a
ver en el siguiente gráfico que la
reapertura se dio el 8 de enero y ya
para finales de mes se tenían resultados
estamos hablando de que en esta escala
en este índice que da cuenta la
actividad de fábricas de China de un de
un cien puntos china se ubicó en el 50,1
Y a partir del 50 es que se empieza a
evaluar que hay en crecimiento de la
actividad lo que podemos ver un
escenario positivo y que además tres
como un puntos más de lo que se reportó
en diciembre cuando se ubicó en el 47
nuestra invitada nos habló acerca de
China y su papel en la Esfera global
creo que en el tema por ejemplo de
tecnología es un digamos escenario que
se presta mucho al discurso no en el
cual pues encontramos obviamente los
intereses europeos los intereses este
americanos dentro de esta carrera por
por el tema de principalmente de los
semiconductores no obstante esto no
quiere decir que digamos que en el
segundo lugar hay esta competencia entre
lo que es China y Estados Unidos y donde
China de alguna forma Durante los
últimos pronunciamientos por parte del
presidente
a prácticamente llevado o direccionado
toda la voluntad china hacia generar
esta autosuficiencia tecnológica que le
lleve digamos estar a la par de de este
de este tipo de innovación tecnológica
no es importante señalar que si bien eh
uno es el diálogo por el tema de de la
parte tecnológica o los bienes
intensivos de capital o de alta
tecnología es también importante señalar
que muchas veces esos esos mercados son
dependientes de las manufacturas chinas
principalmente en lo que son bienes
intermedios y que de alguna manera pues
bueno en ese sentido el comportamiento
de China está ligado este directa o
indirectamente con también los
comportamientos económicos de estos
mercados no es inevitable culturalmente
que china venga cargada de algo de
antagonismo Aunque su reapertura
emocionó mucho a los mercados No
necesariamente Esa fue la reacción del
ides europeos o estadounidenses que no
se dieron a esperar y llegaron todos en
el Foro de davos y es lo que veremos a
continuación empezamos hablando de la
presidenta del Banco Central europeo
Christine lagart donde ella en su
momento dijo algo que será positivo
principalmente para china algo que será
positivo para el resto del mundo pero
tendremos presión inflacionaria sobre
muchos de nosotros Simplemente porque el
nivel de energía que consumió china el
pasado fue ciertamente menor de
consumirán este año la cantidad de gas
natural licuado que ellos comprarán al
resto del mundo será mayor de lo que
hemos visto y no hay tanta capacidad
disponible en términos de petróleo y de
gas otra de las cuales tampoco dio a
esperar pues su reacción fue la
presidenta de la cámara de la de la
presidencia de la comisión europea
exactamente
dice abro comillas china ha estado
alentando abiertamente a las empresas a
que consumen mucha energía en Europa y
en otros lugares a trasladar o parte de
su producción lo hacen con la promesa de
la energía barata bajos costos laborales
y un entorno regulatorio más indulgente
al mismo tiempo en Gran medida china
subvenciona su industria y restringe el
acceso a su mercado y a las empresas de
la Unión Europea por su parte china no
respondió a estas acusaciones y por el
contrario dijo que iba a manejar una
política abierta al extranjero lo que
quiere decir que mientras Estados Unidos
y la Unión Europea se enfocan en la
parte interna china lo hace de manera
externa Esto fue lo que nos dijo nuestra
invitada el hecho de que hoy en día
china se rea también digamos este genera
una especie de fenómeno de aspersor en
la cual pues este no solamente en
términos de consumo sino también por
ejemplo en términos de demanda de de
materias primas reactiva este y dinamiza
a otras economías que están ligadas a a
temas de suministro con China de alguna
forma Pues bueno el hecho de que se
reactive económicamente china al mediano
o largo plazo va a generar impactos en
el tema de la demanda de de combustibles
por el el papel que sigue tomando el
petróleo en el tema de la manufactura
creo que estaremos de acuerdo Juan Pablo
en que este tema nos interesa a todos y
pues los devenirs de la economía gracias
a usted tendremos mucho